Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
marvel spider-man freshman year teaser trailer
video they just released a bunch of comic-con
footage there's a bunch of easter eggs here i will
explain what's going on because some of it doesn't
seem like it matches up with the mcu backstory
for the character but if you're brand new to the
channel i'll be doing videos for all the big comic
con trailers this weekend be sure to subscribe
to get everything at the big marvel panel they'll
be posting the black panther 2 trailer of course
i'll do a video for that they'll make a bunch of
big announcements supposedly avengers 5 is going
to be a version of avengers kang war but they're
going to call it avengers kang dynasty they also
basically soft confirmed that avengers 6 will be
a full-blown secret wars movie so it'll be the
avengers versus kang first and then avengers
full-blown secret wars we'll see when they
actually announce that those movies are going
to be released but the whole idea with spider-man
freshman year is they're doing an animated series
in the style of steve ditko's art like the
animation all the characters of the universe
is meant to look like steve ditko's comic books in
the og spider-man comics picture it as being kind
of like spectacular spider-man episodes mixed with
the 90s spider-man the animated series episodes
and it's going to start with him being in freshman
year with him getting the spider bite and will
follow him through his origin story because he
kind of skipped over that during captain america
civil war but here's the thing because of some
of the footage they released some of the scenes
like norman osborne is a big character during
it ozcorp exists harry osborne existing he has
a relationship with him and there are a bunch of
characters in the backstory for the character is
very different so it sounds like the show is
going to be set in a different universe and
it won't be 616 mcu spider-man like it'll be very
similar but there'll be a couple minor differences
for example like the look of the characters looks
very different looks much more comic book accurate
but much less like mcu versions of the characters
for instance doctor strange looks very different
and in the mcu when daredevil is supposed to get
his back in black suit like the black daredevil
suit during the new daredevil episodes it'll
look a little bit different from this black
suit and yes you heard that right charlie cox
is going to come back as daredevil during the
series it'll be our genuine daredevil spiderman
crossover in a way that you didn't see during
spiderman no way home like that was a spiderman
daredevil crossover but it was more like a matt
murdock spiderman crossover or matt murdock and
peter parker crossover this time it'll be genuine
daredevil doing daredevil things being a vigilante
with spider-man being in this full spider-man
costume although obviously slightly different
version the spider-man costume charlie cox said
this is actually one of the reasons why he came
back so they could do crazy crossovers like this
this is like the beginning of charlie cox coming
back as daredevil in a much bigger way like we saw
some easter eggs because of the kingpin character
during hawkeye he's also supposed to come back in
a slightly different costume during the she-hulk
series and as matt murdock and then during the
echo series another different costume and then
again a different costume during the daredevil
episodes i think it'll be like the yellow suit
a couple of the other daredevil suits and then
it'll be full on back in black like the all-new
all different suit by the time we get to the new
daredevil revival series but that's just the
beginning i know you all have questions about
norman osborne and green goblin because one of
the villains will be norman osborne who based
on the footage in this universe seems like he's
running a version of oscorp and has a pre-existing
relationship with peter through harry osborne like
they did in the comics i believe he and harry are
school friends like they were in the comics and
then he becomes sort of a surrogate father to
peter and it's sort of like a comic book backstory
he cares about peter and his son but he's got all
this shady oscorp stuff going on in the side peter
starts to think of him as a father figure you see
him at his house here this version of aunt may
seems a little bit different from marisa tomei
but the funny thing here is this looks exactly
like the captain america civil war scene just
with slightly different versions of the characters
like it's norman osborne coming here instead of a
version of iron man then eventually he gets the
spider bite we'll see that happen get a version
of that origin story he'll make his first homemade
suit and then as he's having his first adventures
trying to learn to save people use his abilities
norman osborne will learn about spider-man and
try to sort of hijack him like work with him
slowly and then eventually try to twist him
to the dark side like he does in the comics and
in the movies as well join me or die eventually
they also said one of the suits that he's going
to wear during the series will be the osborne
created spider-man suit like norman osborne will
create a new suit for this version of spider-man
i don't know how close it's going to be to the
comic book version but like this is a comic book
version of peter parker wearing a norman osborne
created spider-man suit you can see all the goblin
text sort of baked into it they didn't say during
the series whether or not norman osborne has
already become green goblin but i think that we
probably also see a version that happened during
the series and they also did confirm that they've
renewed it for season two and season two is called
spider-man's sophomore year he was a sophomore
during the events of captain america civil war but
i'm assuming that they would deal with more green
goblin stuff during season two like that would be
a big season one cliffhanger then separately
another group of villains seems like they have
a version of the sinister six they just have not
become the sinister six yet but they all seem like
very core sinister six characters slowly coming
together over the course of the episodes there's
a very comic book accurate looking doctor octopus
there's a scorpion who looks kind of tech based
there's a comic book accurate chameleon
the huge dude is actually supposed to be
a version of rhino when he's not in the costume
i'm not sure who the woman with the blonde hair
with the mohawk is supposed to be but she seems
kind of like a brawler just based on her fists
this female villain with the black hair the
red streak in the blades might be a version
of tarantula because it said tarantula would be
one of the villains and we don't really know who
the third version of the character's supposed
to be but they got tied up with nico minoru
and nico is a character during the series
so this could just be a version of tarantula
i'm not sure who the african-american woman
in the military pants is supposed to be the
firebase villain isn't supposed to be molten man
it's meant to be a version of pyromaniac the dude
with the mechanical legs and the sunglasses
is supposed to be a version of speed demon
a version of tombstone is also supposed to appear
during the series but let me know in the comments
if you do think you know who military pants and
the mohawk are supposed to be some of his allies
that they showed off in the series will be charlie
cox's daredevil like i said slightly different
back in black suit and he'll be the matt murdock
lawyer by day as well there'll be doctor strange
who obviously looks a little bit more comic book
accurate to the original steve ditko dr strange
nico minoru from runaways like i said there's
even a scene of spiderman and doctor strange
both trying to save her from some dark being or
a shadow demon from another dimension because she
comes from a family of dark wizards so that's the
magic based connection to doctor strange we also
just saw a whole lot of spiderman and doctor
strange together during spiderman no way home
we'll see if they break this universe during
this series too also like i mentioned they
have a version of harry osborn he isn't pictured
in this lineup here but he looked like the steve
ditko harry osborne that you remember from the
comics i don't know who the character on the
far right is supposed to be they didn't name her
the guy in the lab coat is actually meant to be
amadeus cho of all people so we'll probably see
some more hulk easter eggs through his character
and maybe some sort of connection to the bruce
banner hulk we do have the she-hulk episodes
coming up so obviously they're doing a version of
jennifer walter she-hulk but i don't know if we're
also going to see any easter eggs for amadeus
cho or other hulk family members there's a lot
of big hulks that they haven't introduced yet like
we're still waiting for red hulk because they just
announced a version of thunderbolts but because
william hurt passed away it'd be really hard
for them to do thunderbolt ross red hulk they'd
have to do a different version of the character
nico is standing next to him like i mentioned and
i don't know who the other three characters to the
right of her are supposed to be or if they're
related to each other or related to the other
evil character with dr octopus with the military
pants because they all kind of look similar so
they could be from the same family and i'm not
sure who the football player is supposed to be
either but he seems like he goes to peter's school
there is no bales character i could find in marvel
comics so you can let me know who you think some
of those characters are in the comments below
the slight variation that they made to his first
homemade spider-man suit is just to have him
wearing a hockey looking jersey with a custom
spider-man symbol on the chest and blue
the colors are just like a little bit different
they're tuned up just a little bit more
it like his pants are just a little bit different
they did confirm there'd be like seven different
spider-man suits on the show including the
first homemade suit in the classic steve ditko
you see in the middle of the lineup here but it's
the red blue suit all five of these suits include
versions of the spider-man slingers team suit
that's the big easter egg here for those of
you that didn't read the slinger storyline that
involved another team of people that spider-man
basically gave his suits to but from left to right
it's hornet the black one is dusk the classic blue
and red steve ditko suit like i said that was his
second suit technically the very first spider-man
suit was meant to be red and black which i talked
about during my spider-man far from home videos
because that inspired the version that he got
during that movie the white suit on the right
of that is either a future foundation suit which
kind of blows my mind because that also means that
the fantastic four were in this universe and this
last one on the right is prodigy it is meant to be
a kevin feige led marvel studios production but
i think it's going to be treated in the way that
they treat what if like it is canon to the marvel
cinematic multiverse but it's taking place in an
alternate universe because like for instance
during spiderman no way home when we have the
tobey maguire green goblin come in and he goes
looking to try and find a version of ozcorp or
find a version of harry osborne he says that
there is no oz corp that exists in the 616 mcu
any implies that this universe's version of harry
osborn has already died so you just post all your
theories in the comments below all your reactions
i do love that they tried to be so accurate to the
original steve ditko art style but that's kind
of the idea with all the marvel animation series
like each of these different giant sears
that they have going that are animated
try to have a very different style and
look to them the only animated shows that
are going to be similar i think are going to be
the marvel what if in the marvel zombies series
because marvel zombies i think is meant to be a
spin-off of what if so it's going to be like the
same people animating it in the same style i've
already done a what if season 2 trailer video so
i'll link that at the end of this and down in the
description but i will do a separate video for the
marvel zombies teaser and i'll do a teaser video
for the new x-men 97 preview that they showed off
in the next couple of days so make sure to enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that
the real big news is that the big marvel panel is
happening later tonight as i'm posting this video
i will do a video for the black panther 2 trailer
next you can click here to watch that i'll update
the link as soon as i post it and you can click
here for my what if season 2 teaser trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!